sur lui que je raconte l'histoire c'est
le faire je vais le faire comme je lé
fais pour relancer mon accident du nez
et de l'arcade sourcillière le mojo
l'enterrement je vous en mets mon
élection à la tête de la commune de
lourdios-ichère seleccion qui était
qu'un venu dans la douleur puisque les
deux listes se poser brutalement très
facile fut élu maire parce que le maire
à ses huit jours après le conseil
municipal
eh oui trois jours après cette élection
pour mir acte officiel
l'enterrement d'un ancien adjoint le
savez diriger deuxième acte officiel le
mariage à ma soeur ce qui ne me rajeunit
pas aussi à 24,1 degrés variés en vain
j'étais un peu tremblant me rendant dans
ce set un terrain tu étais plus jeune
maire de france avec barthélémy aguerre
on n'a jamais su au juste ce qu il était
prêt à l'intérieur on est alors dans
certains camps effectué jeu 6 et alors
ne voilà-t-il pas que l'enterrement
battant son plein je m'étais mis au 4e
ou 5e rame pas précisément au rang de la
famille mais pas trop loin non plus
à côté de mon adjoint qui était adjoint
qui avait une petite soixantaine
d'années à l'époque
non on allait sur les quatre et non plus
voilà non plus je m'en mets et le droit
étaient rassurés voulu mon élection
tous les anciens avec qui je suis le
camp et on était arrivée des nouveaux
traités jeunes tout d'un coup alors
qu'on se dirigeait vers l'élévation le
curé commencent à manifester des signes
et blessent de déséquilibre à l'hôtel si
je le vois très maintenant je me
souviens aussi dès maintenant
quand est-ce à bouger un petit peu dans
tous les sens attentes des peuples et ne
voit-il pâques arrive l'incroyable le
curriculum de toute sa longueur
alors tout le monde le reste on entend
au camp nou le camp de nahr comme les et
tout le monde de rester là qu'on va
devant interloqué qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire quand un curé et ses formes à la
tribune cohn entrepreneurs l'interview
et c'est là que le match commence en
attendant les premiers rôles qu'il a le
maire et voulait être même qu'on aurait
secoué et ce connard d'adjoints qui est
à côté de lui il n'est pas nécessaire de
village soit très grand pour qu'il y ait
de débat d'idées et là j'ai mon adjoint
il faut y aller il vit pour quoi faire
et on me voir et nous nous dirigeons et
nous trouvons quand même le curé très
profondément inerte et un curé très
profondément inerte et très lourd c'est
alors on essaye de le prendre mais il
s'est échappé de partout ils ont glissé
c'est incroyable ce que c'est difficile
de prendre un curé alors je lui dis moi
je la trappe par la tête
il me plaît pas et toi par les pieds
mais comme ça tout doucement grave et on
le traîne la synchronie arrive parce
qu'il était quand même très très nerveux
et interdit problème c'est que s'il
avait sans son train arrière qu'il est
passé sur l'unique marche qui sépare le
maître autel de la sacristie
alors j'y lis pouces d'une étoile bon on
l'a fait face et on a mis là je suis
obligé de raccourcir contenu je veux pas
rater l'autre alors il me dit mais je
crois qu'il est quand même
très malade je me demande de signer même
pas un peu mans le moment on n'est pas
au débat je file à l'auberge la mode
c'était le seul téléphone y aurait un
bal de l'effort à la verrie jeunes être
élu il ya trois jours je vous rappelle
olivia est évident après remarqué et je
vais chez la mode
d'abord je dois raconter la faire à
madame lamente ce qui a pris un certain
temps mais qu'est ce que tu fais là des
balances d'avant jeudi le curé se
trouvait mal quoi le curé mot enfin bref
dans le monde et je téléphone à
sallanches où il y aurait un petit dépôt
de curer le lieu
c'étaient des déchets bétharram it des
lieux de deux états bref il y avait 15 4
5 et là je tombe sur une bonne soeur qui
me dit ouais un but et et pour quoi
faire
il travailla ce serait si oui mais il
m'en faudrait en tout de suite pour
finir je suis guide à kumasi l'avion le
faire mais il est malade il est il
croyait valade julien lui fait bref je
n'en tire pas grand chose finalement
j'arrive à obtenir le principe de
l'arrivée d'un nouveau curé à l'audience
le millier voilà surmely l'avait sur la
la patronne du restaurant midi mais
disons mais tu te préoccuper du curé de
trouver un autre mélodie attendant de
mourir le médecin alors on appelle le
médecin le temps de trouver un médecin
c'est toujours quelque chose puis
finalement le médecin dit j'arrive
immédiatement bon je reviens là ce
christ il l'a rejoint et dépassé vers
toutes les couleurs il me disait que
c'était foutu comme étant moi je serais
vraiment un concert parce que de temps
en temps il est pas tout à fait mort
parce qu'il a menée
on dirait comme on dit à mes années
qu'il fait les dernières à l'instar des
places derrière et il a failli le faire
trente quatre fois à du côté du cac sais
pas s'il y en a un qui arrive alors le
tout il a été le plus rapide le tout mis
par yves d'alors il avait traversé de
l'église je dis surtout pas et du coup
ça a donné l'idée de faire une bande
annonce
allard à l'office j'étais pas très fier
que les radios si vous le faire payer
aux surtout pas jeudi vont vous avez vu
monsieur le curé et tomber brusquement
mal nous le soyons avec l'adjoint est à
l'agenda nouveau et le médecin qui
viennent d'arriver et un autre un autre
le curé va le remplacer d'un moment à
l'autre bon très bien alors lawn le
médecin divorce et une attaque
d'hémiplégie il a le côté droit vraiment
un truc et c'est alors c'est très grave
je vais le chargement de la voiture mais
je recharge et c'est nous qui l'avons
nous c'est d'avoir une certaine habitude
bon et puis il s'en va je me tiens sur
le porche de l'église pour atteindre le
curé puis j'attendais d'eux moment où
l'ordre est effectivement le curé arrive
une 4l du jour comme je disais que c'est
un soleil clair qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup
de luminosité ambiante
je vous l'expliquais en procurer je me
suis dit vas peut-être rendez vous on en
est rendu mais non c'est de teinture est
pressé avec une toute petite sacoche
sous le bras c'était une cure et pas
très haut sur pattes assez rabelais
costaud il monte les marches à 3,4 à 4
du préau qui saoule et de l'analyse
l'avons appellation le
par chance le porche et moi je milite en
prime un négligé comme le devant et
rentrer et puis ensuite il faut marquer
un virage pour aller vers le maître
autel et comme c'était un adjoint on
avait mis le tapis avec les petits trucs
pour le fixer les baguettes et effectue
alors qu'il venait de sortir la plein
soleil sécurisé effectué un virage un
peu sec
il se prend le pied non pas la date mais
à la taille et par la terreur a sous les
yeux horrifiés à ce que j'ai vu tout de
suite ce que ça allait donner
et sa course se termine la tête en avant
sous l'angle sur l'angle du cercueil
étaient là me reposer sur deux tréteaux
le cercueil fait je veux que ça y est on
ne sait pas tomber et le curé qui reste
par terre quand j'en ai entendu quelques
jeunes johnny mais on n'était pas plus
avancé pour aubin alors là comme j'ai
commencé à voir une certaine maîtrise de
la faire je fais signe à la joue et qui
me dit on va qu'un pas remettre ça tu te
mets au pied et mois il puisse faire ça
c'était un chaos nous le transporter
dans la tribune à la sacristie et la
gélule y occupe toi de son arrivée
ça va aller plus vite je le premier je
vais appeler à nouveau tout vie et un
nouveau curé et jeudi tarde pas trop
parce que c'est grave très pénible et je
repars j'ai de nouveaux marins de la
mode qui me dit mais il n'est pas fini
ce danger mais non on a le régime curé
qui est blessé la minime et vous êtes
complètement fou mais qu'est ce que vous
leur faites à se plier à ses curés
je l'avais dit que ça se terminerait mal
ici
ce virage j'ai le téléphone j'appelle
d'abord le tome i parce que je me dis
quand même la première fois j'avais fait
le trou alors la femme du tout vite me
dit mais ça y est on à la commission on
le sait qui est blessé mon mari est déjà
parti et non mais c'est pas ça il ya là
deux avec vous des jeux comme marie mai
le sait il peut faire va pas soigner
tous les curés mais qu'est ce que vous
leur faites aux purées et puis
finalement elle même dit que l'intrus un
autre mais de celles qui allaitent
arrivés promptement judy peut arriver
avec du matériel à coudre et puis je
rappelle ce sens là même bonheur quoi
aujourd'hui hausse ses poulains de
berlin ouais vous l'avez pas adhéré en
corée ce mois mais on vous en a envoyé
un regret oui mais lui aussi les il est
malade mais je voulais mettre leurs
goûts et vous plaise à tous les états
qu'ils aient voté peu importe si vous
pouviez retrouver en troisième un
troisième nom je le trouvais écouter ce
sera le dernier que vous et moi et
finalement j'ai réussi à obtenir un
troisième cure et alors là je vais à
l'église
et puis je me dis là il faut que je
trouve deux mois que je les alignent
correctement la famille au premier rang
parce que ça fait quand même trois
quarts de l'enterrement avait démarré si
bon vous avez vu ce qui se produiront
des événements qui nous dépasse si
certains d'entre vous veulent sortir un
moment ils le peuvent découvrir iv
monsieur le curé vont rentrer un nouveau
curé arrive pas et il m'a semblé
entendre au milieu sanglots quelques
éclats de rire confondues lesquels
peuvent très bien se marier d'ailleurs
incertaine circonstances et je reste sur
le pas de la porte beaucoup de gens sont
sortis et là je vais arriver un curé
beaucoup plus calme qui viennent à moi
me lis souvent le seraient bientôt
d'enterrement musclée
j'ai des coups de monsieur le curé
joseph b aucun risque inutile
ayez ou est ce qu'ils n'en sont arrivés
les premiers
le premier détail et à l'élévation le
vent il n'a rien pu faire alors allez
droite on débute
si vous pouviez finir permettre ce mort
en terre et tous assurent que je vous en
serai éternellement reconnaissant mais
faites gaffe fait jamais deux sans trois
le livre est brute d'ailleurs il l'a été
ça n'a pas traîné mais bien qu'ils
n'aient pas traîner au moment où
l'intérêt il est quand même tous ceux
qui étaient partis à l'auberge
quand même se raconter comme toute cette
histoire et faire le plus est récapitulé
la situation qui fait que les premiers
chants nous arriver montagne est versée
au départ et même quelques autres nous
arrivait au cimetière comme porte
étendard
l'ancien adjoint de lourdios ce jour là
je me suis dit que tout était très
relatif
voilà comment on a fait le premier
enterrement voilà quel a été mon premier
acte de mer 1 2 l'autriche est la même
en le faisant courir